so
well as uh i already i have been
introduced
introduction and uh well my name is
wilder i worked at vada fonzigo
and i'm gonna talk about deep learning
for object detection but then
it's not really a deep dive into any
particular model so it's more like how
we actually apply it from a telco
or like from an industry perspective but
of course i'm going to mention like a
few things
as we move uh through the the
presentation
and uh well just drop your questions on
on the question
on the chat and i'm also on discord so
like uh don't waste the time
just make sure that you get whatever you
need
uh as agenda so we're gonna have a quick
look like
at vodafone zero per se i'll just do my
sales speech
not a very lengthy one then we
dive into the business case that we have
and how we actually solved it with
with object detection but also like
going through the the issues that we
faced along the way for instance like
how do we collect data but then
afterwards we have to clean the date and
then the labeling
all of this together to actually be able
to create a data set that we can use for
training
and depending on the amount of data that
you have you can also
have some augmentation in place and what
we actually have done
to make sure that we could increase the
amount of images that we have
to before we could train a model and
then we go a little bit into the model
the training and the inference part of
it
uh and of course making sure that we can
that we can also show some aspects of
soft engineering in terms of
how can we automate it how how can we
modularize the project
to avoid have this uh monolith with some
deep learning code here some soft code
there which is not
helpful just
a little bit of uh the evolution through
the ears
uh so it's funny to put it in this way
because if you look at the the first day
there so then you can see
like uh well almost 200 years ago right
so then you
could actually have this you had this
the first cable being like
just laid through the the atlantic
impressive fine so then almost 100 years
after that
we could start using it like for have
like phone calls with
240 uh phone calls like simultaneously
which is okay not that much it took only
like 100 years
fine but then just like with moore's law
uh in a period of like 30 years
approximately
so we already had like a way more way
more like simultaneous calls uh
like connected which is like very
interesting and then after that we got
to like 2006
with speeds going up to like 400 mega
megabits per second
in terms of download 120 and upload and
then it took
like a 13 years to get to like one gig
bit per second which is actually
what for the fonzigo has now so we see
like that
well the technology actually increases
uh
very rapidly and then we should also
make use of technology to help us
within our like a day-to-day job and the
processes that we actually follow when
we deliver product
to just put it in context like how to
apply all this speed within like
vodafone ziggle
uh with our new product that has been
launched the
last year the giganet which actually due
to
corona kind of had some change in there
in terms of rollout
uh but still like we had a 4 000
or 40 000 kilometers of optical fiber
throughout the the country so then as
you can see it's almost the country's
covered by
by this optical fiber uh which
represents 97
of the signals that are transmitted
throughout to our customers
uh but of course we also have crux of
cables and then that's where
the whole dark season 3.1 uh history
comes in place
because from the street cabinets that we
have as you might have noticed
silly got confused with something i said
sorry uh
so then we have street cabinets like all
around the place
in the country where you can actually so
get your quartz cable from the street
cabinet
into the houses and then there you
actually have your
your internet connection also like
telephone and
uh and tv being served
in terms of what we can take out of this
uh
one gigabit per second so we just have
some download speed like
uh numbers over there comparing it like
giganet
again like versus the average
subscription that someone would have
so it's quite impressive we don't have
to go through and read all this thing
but it's more or less where we actually
stay now in the
in the dutch market but then how can he
it actually like okay we understood the
quest cable like a bit of a history on
that but also like
how it actually impact our business but
then what can we
do it with it like how can it actually
impact our customers
and what could we do with uh
object detection to help customers so
inside every house there is a an in-home
like an intake point
where actually the quarks cable comes in
and connects to it so in the
picture there in the middle uh it's this
uh it's the
the thing on the wall the socket where
the model is connected to
so the thing is it's a very important
and a weak link within our journey
because what we want to is to actually
make sure that the customers are able to
do self-installation
so then the customer get uh gets the
product at home
then just open the box they install it
everything is working
great but it doesn't really work like
this for about like 26
of our customers so the customer goes to
the website buys a product
fine it's confirmed in about like two
weeks time they get the box at home
they try to install it they fail they
fail because they bought a product
that's not compliant with installation
that they have at their place
what does it mean that next to that
they're going to make a call
to actually schedule like well first to
solve the problem
but then the call center person will say
that look i cannot solve it for you
you need like a technician and then to
get a technician it's going to take
another yeah
on average like two weeks depending on
how it goes now probably like a bit less
because not everybody is super busy but
then
it actually might add like a four weeks
delay
from when you purchase the product and
and then you can actually
start using it and in meantime of course
your
subscription if the previous provider
could just be cancelled
and you just find yourself in a position
where okay
look i'm not going to do this anymore
and then we have there the second
number of churns that we have like
customers just give up and then they
call back the competitors and say look
please don't cancel my contract because
i'm just giving up on this
so this is a this is a big thing and our
idea so what we want to achieve is to
through the my ziggler app be able to
help the customer too
you made a purchase of a certain product
so once that purchase is confirmed
you then get a link like an sms please
if you want to
do a check of what kind of installation
you have at your place
basically just to check your aop and
then the customer with the mobile phone
can just go there
take a picture and then on the spot the
customer will know
okay so that's what i got is it good and
then we're gonna tell yes this is good
you're good to go you don't have to do
anything
you've got the boxes doing the
installation yourself in the case
uh the aop is not good what you're gonna
tell the customer is like
look please click on this link and just
plain a visit from an
engineer to slash technician to actually
do the installation for yourself because
some components will have to be replaced
so that is actually going to put the
customer in a very good position
where they get the box
and then it's installed because the the
engineer will just come along
so that's perfect but then how
can we actually get a data set in place
to be able to to do this so
it took quite some time from uh from
some colleagues that invested like uh
i mean like sometime in looking into
well
we see like a vessel there a good friend
of mine he's not he didn't
he didn't do it on his own like just
going through containers and collecting
stuff but uh he's kind of the father of
the baby
uh with the idea of like how can we
collect images who's gonna collect the
images
so to be able to do that uh we got a
third party to develop an application
uh i will dig into details in a little
bit but just like uh
going through going through like uh
collecting pictures summing it up to
like 47 000 images
and then we increase data quality by
removing
about like a 10k images that we consider
like to be like
to have a poor quality and then doing
the labeling
uh so it was about like three months
of collecting data and then
six months in like cleaning modeling
building
and deploying it so then like uh in
terms of
end-to-end from zero to to have
something running
uh we we had to work for about like nine
months on this
so to start with the movie maker
application
uh we so this application was built uh
and given to the technicians so then
every time a technician would go to a
house
to do some maintenance work they would
take pictures of the aop
so in a very simple way select the type
of aop
select the time of splitter if any and
then the application would make pictures
automatically
uh because we selected the aop and we
selected the splitter so they would end
up in different buckets on s3 so then it
also helps us to actually look
oh let's then focus on the certain types
of aops because we also have an idea
about the distribution
uh in the country so we can say well
because six percent
is represented by this particular type
we should
perhaps like focus on the this first for
instance so
that's fixed we collected like lots of
pictures like in a very quick way so the
pictures are taken automatically the
the technician would just uh rover the
over the the mobile phone over the aop
and then
within a few seconds like 50 pictures
would be taken
but then okay so we we got the tech
we got the business case that actually
would save
quite some money when we look within
like
a year uh and we got the data set but we
also got a problem
and this problem was related to the
quality of the images because sometimes
the technicians were just like moving
the phone
very fast and then we got like blurry
images like
distortions there sometimes they didn't
move it at all so then we got like
almost 50 very similar images
but like very similar images uh looking
like
really the same so what then we did we
use the variance of laplace uh
from opencv so then it's just available
via opencv so it does it convolves like
a small filter
uh over a three by three field over the
images
and then it tries to identify like the
regions of the image
where the intensity changes a lot so
then
then it gives you a score of the how
blurry that image is
so then of course what we did first look
at some images
and okay so this is blurry this is the
score
and then we just use that as a threshold
to kind of uh
cut out some not so good images another
thing that we did which is not
not in this slide uh we use like the
histogram of gradients of the images
and then we calculate like the cosine
distance between images within the same
category
to actually uh try to identify okay how
similar those images are
and then just get rid of some of them so
about like two percent of the images
were like very similar we just removed
them and then the rest were just like
very blurry images
we fixed that fine so data set is clean
we are ready to go
but then now we have to label it of
course for object faction
you have to go over the images and uh
draw the bounding boxes on the objects
that
you want to detect what did we use for
labeling
we used everything that we could get our
handle at
uh and that being like we started with a
proof of concept
using microsoft v ott which is quite
good it's open source
integrated with azure you can write your
own uh
module if you want to integrate it with
s3 i don't know if it's already there
but at least six months ago it was not
uh and then we labeled like uh about 600
images to
just have like a proof of concept going
and see how it would work
we proved a point it worked fine and
then we moved to
aws ground truth as a more like well
robust solution that would be able to
help us
with like integrating it with s3 also
having like a mood
tenant features to be able to create
like a
users or just to link it up with uh
active directory or ldap so then the
technicians could do the labeling for us
like help us a little bit
then finally we did some labeling with
ground truth but then we had some uh
some drawbacks there with like uh
the outputs and so the output from
ground truth was not really good and
then we had to write lots of uh
scripts to make sure that okay we got to
a certain format that we need
and then now we are moving to opencv
sivat
which is uh it was open source last year
by intel
it's an amazing tool and it has like
lots of interesting features
so uh just as a note if you are looking
for
a platform to do labeling uh so
what we look at is like what we want to
have as features like what that platform
is going to offer us
that we consider to be important is
standardized exporting import formats
for instance
ms coco pascal uh voc
tensorflow records yolo so the
the tools should be able to export and
import
in that format so then it helps us
semi-automatic labeling like for
instance a cvat has it
and and microsoft qt as well
and be able to use like uh custom models
to do
like active learning mutant cloud ready
so it gives you freedom if you use
something that's open source you can
just deploy it on
amazon or google cloud or whatever
that's amazing
so we labeled about 80 000 images
8 000 images and and then
fine so we got the data set we cleaned
it we labeled it
but then 8 000 it's actually not enough
uh
it is for certain categories but then
certain number of categories but we had
like uh
34 categories from like eops and
splitters
and that was just a little bit too much
so we had to
play a little bit with data augmentation
of
our images and there
we used tensorflow like just tensorflow
native like brightness saturation
hue and contrast to just apply to our
like data set
uh our data set has been converted to
tensorflow records so then it was easier
to
uh to just manipulate like the the
tensors and then
make sure that we could use the all the
resources that we have from the
tensorflow data set api in terms of
mapping it and then just doing those
transformations on the data sets
on the data set and for image
augmentation in terms of
rotations because then rotating
uh an image that has a bounding box it's
not as trivial
as we do with image classification only
on image classification you just rotate
the image itself and then that's fine or
you share it or you cut
off whatever but when you have uh
a bounding box there you have to rotate
it share it
etc and then for that we use the eagle
image augmentation library which is also
open source
to apply those transformations on the
images as you can see on the pictures on
the right
so we turned our 8k images into like 32k
and then we went on for on uh on
training
and an inference and well some transfer
learning before that
but okay so just a quick point here like
important one
uh when we first trained it with only
about like uh
2000 images augmented of course uh and
got up to like 10 to 12 000 images
it already worked very well because the
the the objects that were
we want to identify like very simple and
so the shapes are
they look the same the features that are
actually extracted
within the the cnn blocks in the in the
yellow model
uh they are like just like tiny
differences so then we're like able to
detect
the the aops that we wanted to detect in
the first phase like
quite well so we end up i don't remember
the recall now but we end up with a
precision of eight seven percent
for instance which is good uh we had to
throw up uh to throw away
like uh uh like the
biggest data the largest data set we had
the 6k
because we had some issues with the with
like the amazon consolidation the ground
truth consolidation
and we actually the data set was
corrupted and it just
messed up the the model so so that's why
we're moving to
to cvat but okay so
in picking up the model so fast is bad
in this case
because our vision is to actually have
the model embedded on mobile phones
so now it works as a as a service that
it's just called so the service is
deployed on amazon
and that service is just consumed by by
a client in this case a mobile phone or
a browser
but like we want to have it embedded so
yolo v3 so we didn't move to yolo v4 yet
so your v3 gives uh in terms of accuracy
it's
slightly uh below uh
for instance uh uh the the fast rcnn
but it's it's very fast because of the
way that it works
uh during the influence because it's
actually just uh
like uh doing uh iou on top of the boxes
that
uh it has as anchors and then the boxes
that it should predict
it has like a logistic regression
approach on top of it
so it's very fast it's just a matter of
converting it to
uh tensorflow uh light or to
we have tensorflow now but we also plan
to to try out the pi
torch and then converting it to
pythagoras mobile to have it deployed on
the
mobile phones uh to train with
such a small data set we actually
initialized
the weights of of our model uh with
the dark net 53 weights which are which
have been produced by a
yellow v3 after being trained on the the
coco 2007
data set and the model which uses the
latest tensorflow now so
we keep updating it and making sure that
it's compatible with
just latest and greatest greatest
tensorflow that is
released uh it was developed in-house of
course
based on some initial uh code from
darknet53 from the git the public
repository that they have
uh and then we did our fine tuning in
terms of uh like
learning rate in terms of adding the
augmentations
and also like changing the whole like
data set uh
the data the way the data set is
processed because
the original model was using just tf
records
and we moved away from tf records to use
the latest
data set api uh binaries
so we got this one also fixed and the
training going
but then of course so i think
it's easier for everybody to let's say
you get a data set you label it i mean
in terms of
images it's quite easy to to acquire
images if you have the rights to use
them
uh and then from there if you think
about the model either for
classification
or object detection it's also pretty
easy to get you can find models like
implementations on the internet
even if you don't want to change them or
to to make them better or to update
versions etc
but then to bring something to
production is a bit different than
because you cannot
have a notebook running in production
so you can do like uh one can do
whatever one wants in terms of uh
experimenting with notebooks but when
you have to run something you have to
make it more
let's say software like in terms of you
need packages you need like modules you
need tests you need like
the whole cicd pipeline running as it
was uh
very well uh presented in the previous
talk
so what we did first we broke down the
whole
the original dark 53 code that we got
into modules to make sure that we can
reuse them and then
and that we can also like work
independently in certain modules for
instance
for the inference part i i don't care
what's going on on the the model uh
definition
because i just need like a model a
binary and then i want to do inference
so for me it's just like it's an api
offering that i have so then we created
like
five projects with very good names uh we
have
warlock which is uh it does the whole
formation of labeling and inference
so then warlock is based on cloud
formation
uh so we work like very close with
the data engineers to help us out with
the automation when we cannot do it
ourselves uh we have forge which
actually contains
all the the code related to the model
definition so the
picture is reading forge and forge also
has all the pre-processing and all the
wood use
utilities that we need for instance all
the communication with s3
it stays within forge and those are like
separate repositories
by the way then we move to like storm we
stopped us on the training automation
and why is uh storm not next to warlock
uh but it's at the same time in
automation
because when we started uh we didn't
have like a data engineer with us
and we didn't know a cdk so then we
decided to actually okay
we know to have form so let's just do
the automation of the training with the
form because we have to get going so we
also took the responsibility on make
things uh
going through uh then cyclops does
all the training and uh and it's fully
dockerized
so then the way it happens is a storm
when we run the storm it actually
fetch a docker image from ecr from the
alaska container registry from amazon
and then it just deploys that image uh
and runs it it runs it as a container
within
aws in a machine there that storm
actually creates so a storm
spins up the whole aws infrastructure
pulls the docker image runs it and then
the train
the training gets going and and we have
cerebral
which is then pulled it's also a darker
image
that's pulled by warlock and then uh
offers the service to our customer
customers
so in terms of uh so just a little bit
on training and inference automation
uh that's what is created by storm so
then
we have like the whole infrastructure
there in a vpc a visual private cloud
if it's on private subnet for instance
which we have access like only us
so then some some ssh keys are deployed
in the machine so then we can actually
connect to it to follow up on training
uh once the training is done
both the the tensorflow or tensorboard
uh logins are moved to a cop
two s3 and also the model and uh and
then we have all the things that you can
think of in terms of yeah
checking out on the learning rates and
monitoring it making sure that we change
it over time
uh also like uh checking okay so
load the weights from the previous
models that have been trained and then
you start from there
so then and then that's more or less how
it goes
and just this is the face of our
customers
when we actually deliver a box and they
cannot install them
the box like the product themselves it's
very frustrated
frustrating like it happened to me as
well it happened to
william a colleague and friend who
went through the same so this uh this
two for us is actually
of a very very high importance
i will try to i'll do a quick demo if i
have time yes i have two minutes
i'll do a quick demo in 30 seconds uh
because
to show you guys more or less how it
works so this is running on my localhost
because i didn't want to open up the
the url so we asked for
permission to store the picture because
we closed the feedback loop on
retraining based on pictures that
customers
uploaded so that's something i forgot to
mention so the whole
machine learning life cycle is a closed
feedback loop i can so i get some
examples of what i should look if i
don't know what in the what an
eop is i can just look inside the house
the fuse box and i can find
something similar to this box here box
here and
i blow the picture so this one is
at my place so yes fine and good for
gigabit
so i i have it i have the product i can
also like
try with something else like from
another colleague
also good we have some images that we
actually collected from
those images are from the wild so we
collected from uh
from the fonzigo forum where from the
zebra forum where people go to complain
about the installation
so this is good if we check for
something that's actually
not good so we got this and then from
this
point on the
customer can just go and do the the
whole scheduling procedures
which is pretty nice and then it it
helped us
uh a lot i think i can
stop sharing now and we can move on to
questions if any hey
that's an awesome presentation thanks
also for including the demo
yeah i have i have actually quite a few
interesting questions first of all how
was your experience with ground truth
was it expensive for you guys
with so many images at a large
resolution
well it's been recorded right
yeah so uh ground truth is expensive
yeah it's a bit expensive so uh we got
uh the the people from for instance like
the date engineering team because
uh we sit on the same the the same unit
and they were like that this is very
expensive this is very expensive
uh it didn't go above above the budget
but it's expensive and we didn't use the
mechanical turret so we just used ground
truth per se
we did the labeling and the technicians
did the labeling
so okay you see if you go to the
mechanical turk
then it becomes a bit more expensive but
we didn't go there
uh so that that's another reason we are
moving to uh
to cvat because with cvat you can just
deploy it with fargate
and it's super cheap right especially if
you're going to be labeling them
yourself
yes yeah much cheaper so maybe a good
caveat for our
audience to know or would you yes yes
yeah like not another thing to about
labeling ourselves it's uh
so we are considering now like uh
creating more jobs like hiring
hiring like uh some students you know to
to do the labeling because
uh they follow the instructions like
quite good like my daughter she did some
labeling for me one day
and it went like really good uh i didn't
pay her but i have to
but it was just a test because we had
some some bad results with the
technicians labeling because they want
to do it really fast
and then they didn't they didn't do it
really good right and follow up question
on that
is uh did you try any uh transfer
learning methods to
like have a head start and reduce the
amount of labels you need
uh so we transferred like the dark 53
darknet 53 a weight just at least to
initialize the weights it helped a lot
because like
i think after 30 epochs on on
12 000 images augmented already so we
can get to quite a nice
quite nice score uh we didn't
uh try to to do like a transfer learning
from a perspective of
like a freezing layers because the
objects we have they are like the same
shape you know so we don't get
much from for example if you get the
whole uh
cocoa data set with 80 categories but
then there you have like
computers kites uh cars people
and the the shapes are not like the same
you know like
very diverse type of objects and then
for us it wouldn't bring
that much value so that's why we
transferred only weights
right yeah and then another question uh
we have is how many false positives
negatives do you get or are allowed how
are you finalizing that uh so from
from the business well they asked they
asked me about accuracy right so then
they asked for like an accuracy of 80
so we did calculated like a recall and
and precision so our precision was about
like 87 percent
uh the recall i don't remember but uh
i would have to look back and then just
put on the chat because we do have a
document with the numbers but i don't
remember all of them yeah
right and like you said you're available
on discord and you're very active there
so people are very much
welcome to reach out to you there yeah
yeah sure yeah
cool awesome thanks for the talk and uh
then we go on a 30-minute break
and uh yeah we resume at three o'clock
cool yeah
thank you for the opportunity yeah thank
you thank you thanks
you